З моменту призначення Курта Волкера спецпредставником США з питань України 7 липня,
він активно взявся за врегулювання «гарячої війни». Так Волкер назвав ситуацію
на Сході України під час свого першого візиту в зону АТО. Відтоді роль США в українському питанні
змінилася: зі стороннього спостерігача, який підтримував «мінські» ініціативи та санкції проти Росії, на активного гравця.
У липні цього року Волкер побував на Донбасі, 21 серпня провів перемовини в Мінську
з представником Росії, а 23 серпня разом із главою Пентагону Джеймсом Меттісом відвідує Україну.
Мета: подальші кроки до встановлення миру на Донбасі та відновлення територіальної цілісності України.
Для її досягнення США не приєдналися до формату «Нормандської четвірки», натомість створили
власний формат – посередника між Москвою та Києвом. Поки що політика США не до вподоби Кремлю
з однієї причини: Америка не знімає з порядку денного питання надання Києву летальної зброї.
Нині американці проводять спільні з українцями військові навчання, постачають в Україну нелетальне озброєння та екіпірування.
Утім нещодавно Пентагон та Держдепартамент США надали Білому дому план щодо надання Україні оборонної зброї.
Курт Волкер не вважає, що це дестабілізує ситуацію на Донбасі та спровокує Росію
зробити щось, чого вона ще не зробила. В інтерв’ю ВВС Волкер заявив, що це має допомогти Києву захищатися та зупинити агресію Росії в Україні.
Йдеться передусім про протитанкові ракетні комплекси «Джавелін». У Києві очікують, що США –
через чотири роки російсько-українського протистояння на Донбасі та окупації Криму – таки зважиться
на надання зброї. Утім, попри очевидне для України «так», є чимало «проти».
Надання США летальної зброї Україні може покласти край солідарності Америки та ЄС у політиці щодо Росії.
Західні експерти наголошують: США прекрасно розуміють, що перемогти Росію у воєнний спосіб
Україні не вдасться навіть із американською зброєю. Тиснути треба на слабке місце Кремля – економіку.
Втім, не виключено, що обіцянки надати летальну зброю Києву, –своєрідна дипломатична зброя на перемовинах
між Вашингтоном та Кремлем. Поступ Москви означав би перемогу Трампа на тлі
«мінських домовленостей», які зупинили ескалацію на Сході України, але не війну.